si un vaccin contre le coc vie de 19 été
trouvé 20% des français refuseraient
totalement d'être injectés et 21 % se
disent plutôt opposés à l'idée de se
faire vacciner
ce chiffre confirme une tendance bien
ancrée dans notre pays
la défiance envers la vaccination dans
les années 50 trois vaccins sont
obligatoires pour les nouveau-nés contre
la poliomyélite la diphtérie et le
tétanos
à l'époque une partie des français se
posent des questions
interrogation portait ici par un
journaliste en 1959 j'ai entendu dire
que ces vaccinations était dangereuse
est ce exact
on ne peut nier que l'injection de
vaccin ne provoque quelques réactions la
grande majorité des médecins défendent
la vaccination il met en avant le
progrès sanitaire qu'elle représente
pour nos sociétés comme la en 1962 il
est depuis 1954 la ligue pour la liberté
de vaccination regroupe les plus
sceptiques des français de tous horizons
sociaux
en voici en 1980 les gens sont
conditionnés dans le système vaccinale
parce qu'il manque d'informations la
formation
des accidents ne circule pas beaucoup
plus d'accidents que
black series vol qu'elle prétend que les
accidents de vaccination selon la ligue
il serait la cause de maladie ou de mort
subite chez les nouveau nés
même si le lien n'est pas clairement
établi avec la vaccination
les parents doutent notamment après une
affaire en 1986 quatre morts subites qui
seraient dus aux vaccins tetra coke
c'est en 2017 que les anti vaccins se
sont le plus exprimés juste avant la
promulgation de l'extension à 11 vaccin
obligatoire pour la petite enfance
cette loi a été votée car des maladies
comme la rougeole ressurgissent la
vaccination était jusque-là recommandé
mais pas de quoi convaincre tous les
français est malade il faut vivre avec
sa conscience ne peut pas être
absolument protéger à cent pour cent de
toutes les maladies ans n'est pas
immortel
pour moi c'est une question que de
grossouvre on n'est pas dans ce quelque
chose de la santé publique
aujourd'hui c'est le potentiel vaccin
contre le coc vide et qui a ses
pourfendeurs
la france compte parmi les pays les plus
réfractaires au monde en chine par
exemple 3 % de la population se dit
défavorable
ces 16 % en grande-bretagne contre 41%
en france et 46% en russie
[Musique]